also meinen anteilen die ereignisse
überschlagen sich inzwischen wird die
rede von wladimir putin
wiederholt offenbar gab es so hat der
kreml sprecher gesagt probleme mit einem
server wir gehen direkt in die reederei
sie würden eine blockade unterworfen sie
würden systematisch
durch kanonen beschossen es wurden
bomben geworfen das ist all das was wir
als genozid und
menschen befreien von griechen leiden im
olymp biologen genozid das ist das
hauptziel der militäroperationen wie wir
im don bosco in der ukraine begonnen
haben und da kommen sie kommen mir worte
aus der heiligen schrift in den kopf es
gibt keine größere liebe
du siehst wenn einer
seine seele gibt für seine freunde
im video
sehen die die helden haben
unsere jungs handeln und kämpfen in
dieser operation
[Applaus]
geht es aber
dieses wort
aus der heiligen schrift
des christentums
denen teuer ist die diese religion aus
und alles besteht doch darin dass das
ein universeller wert ist für alle
völker und vertreter aller religionen
russland jetzt besonders für unser volk
in erster linie für unser volk und
der beste beweis dafür
die tatsache wie unsere jungs handeln
und kämpfen in dieser mit der operation
schulter an schulter sie helfen einander
sie unterstützen einander
werden sie
mit ihrem körper
teamkameraden schützen wie den eigenen
bruder vor den kugeln so eine einigkeit
hatten wir lange nicht
[Applaus]
es ist so geschehen dass der beginn der
operation
die wiederholung
das wird immer so sein vielen dank
[Applaus]
und da sind wir also wieder entfernt
sind das heißt das war kurz vor ende
seiner rede als plötzlich das russische
staatsfernsehen die übertragung
unterbrochen hatte und alte bilder die
eine halbe stunde alt war jubel bilder
aus dem stadion einblendet wir haben
lange gerätselt wie kann das passiert
dann bei einer so wichtigen rede am
achten jahrestag der annexion der krim
wo routine sich und sein volk vor der
ganzen welt feiern konnte einfach ein
fehler in der regie hat sich jemand
verdrückt das kann nicht sein bei mir im
studio er ist bild tv chefredakteur
claus strunz wir sind vom fernsehen
klaus wir wissen es kann mal was schief
gehen selten bei uns aber es kann
passieren
eine unglaubliche geschichte eine
absolut unglaubliche geschichte und die
ist natürlich noch nicht zu ende erzählt
wie peter richtig andeutet werden da
jetzt weitere spekulationen kommen und
ich frage mich die ganze zeit was war
ich das sind dieser rede eher den sie
war inhaltlich enttäuschen sie hat das
gebracht was putin immer bringt peter
das analysiert die mischung aus militär
und kirche sie war wahnsinnig kurz sie
hatte keine wirkliche steigerung in sich
ist einer der so würde er es
wahrscheinlich sagen größten führer die
es auf dieser welt gibt ein diktator
erster ausprägung rhetorik kann ja
eigentlich heute hat er komplett versagt
was war also der sinn es war vielleicht
das in ein schauspiel zu machen guckt
mal so viele leute stehen noch hinter
mir das wird aber ein bisschen schade
wenn man herausfindet dass die ins
stadion reingehen sich registrieren auf
der anderen seite wieder rausgehen dass
man hinterher sagen kann da waren
hunderttausende oder irgendwie sowas
also alles was die propagandamaschine
putin normalerweise bis zur vollendung
beherrscht er dort ausgesehen wie ein
laienspiel theater eines debütanten und
das in einer so wichtigen phase dieser
weltkrise das schon überraschend oder
war sein signal einfach nur hallo leute
schaut mal ich bin pumperlgesund ich bin
vital ich bin in der lage dieses land zu
führen weil es ja doch immer wieder auch
spekulationen gab über geisteszustand
über körperlichen zustand weil man in
ewig nicht gesehen hat weil er dann in
seinem helikopter kamen dann hat er da
diese merkwürdige rede gehalten gestern
wenn ich mich recht entsinne
vielleicht war es auch ein signal an die
leute ich bin tatsächlich noch ein
vitaler anführer lasst euch vom westen
und deren propaganda nichts einreden wir
russen müssen zusammenhalten und wir
lösen auch diese krise und diesen
einsatz wie er es nennt wenn man das
jetzt einmal und das kann man ja gar
nicht anders
bezeichnet als das was es ist ist es das
verlogene schauspiel seit ganz langer
zeit denn parallel laufen ja eigentlich
die bilder von granaten von toten von
frauen und kindern auf der flucht und
das eigentliche bild dieses krieges im
fernsehen ist diese verlogene rede und
dann eben die bilder der einschläge was
dieser mann und seine armee anrichteten
und er sagt er befreit die menschen vom
genozid während er tatsächlich diese
gehen und sie diese kriegsverbrechen war
das haben doch alle diese diktatoren
ansicht die wollen immer irgendwas
befreien von irgendwas und lösen damit
riesige krisen und kriege aus und wir
sehen ja nun die bilder ich meine wir
gehen wir für eine ganz kleine sekunde
in die propaganda situation rein aber
dann wohl wo sind denn nun kommen denn
dann diese millionen menschen her die
aus der ukraine fliehen wenn es da gar
kein krieg gibt
sind diese ganze zerschossenen häuser
die uns paul ronzheimer jeden tag zeigt
und die menschen die dort
abtransportiert werden sind die in einem
hollywood studio produziert oder was
herr putin das gibt es ja alles das weiß
die ganze welt und sie wissen es auch
und das ist das verlogene daran was geht
in einem mann vor der die wahrheit kennt
und die lüge propagiert
und wie kann man mit so jemandem jemals
wieder am verhandlungstisch sitzen und
das finde ich das gruseligste so wird
sie ja gucken wenn wir mal ein paar
wochen paar monate hoffentlich ein paar
tage voraus denken dann wird es
verhandlungen geben wo man mit diesen
typen an einem tisch sitzen muss und zu
tun muss als sei er ein sadist
aktionsfähig air partner auf augenhöhe
dabei seien verlogen der diktator der
von christlicher nächstenliebe
spricht während er die menschen dort
bombardiert lass uns noch mal
reinschauen diese momente wohin gerade
in moskau im stadion als er seine große
propaganda show abziehen wollte und als
ihm das eigene
staatsfernsehen dass diese propaganda
hinaus tragen sollte das wort
abgeschnitten hat wir schon noch mal
rein es
ist so passiert dass der beginn des
einsatzes
zusammen viel mit einem und weise also
dieser moment und ja man könnte man
könnte eigentlich drüber lachen wenn die
ganze situation nicht so dramatisch
ernst wäre aber ist natürlich bedeutet
dass auch er hat seinen eigenen laden
nicht mehr im griff wenn selbst also
sein wichtigstes propaganda instrument
das fernsehen nicht mehr so funktioniert
wie er sich das vorstellt also wir
können jetzt mal die die dinge die in
der analyse auch auf kam als wir nicht
genau wusste was es war uns die
erklärung noch nicht gehabt noch immer
weiss man ja nicht was es war aber jetzt
gibt es eine erklärung also es war kein
anschlag erlebt offensichtlich zweiter
hacker waren es wahrscheinlich auch
nicht sonst hätten sie was anderes
verbreitet als nur zu stören aber
vielleicht war es ja doch jemand in der
regie der so ähnlich wie marin die
mutige marina die halt ein plakat
hochgehalten du hast die ganze welt
gesehen hat der jetzt gesagt hat ich
sitze hier am regler und ich kann es
selber nicht mehr hören dann ja dann ist
klar wie das schicksal dieses mannes
oder dieser mutigen frau aussehen wird
aber die für die vorstellung dass bei
einem solchen moment der so durch
inszeniert ist dass zehntausende
menschen in ein stadion kommen wo der
mann dann sechs minuten auftritt und
dann gehen sie wieder nach haus so was
gibt's alles gibt's ja sozusagen
eigentlich überhaupt nicht dass da im
entscheidenden moment der server
ausfällt
das gehört glaube ich auch in die in die
propagandamaschine und ins reich der
propaganda man kann es sich nicht
vorstellen dass eine server ausfällt
tatsächlich in dieser situation ein
moment der wochen lang vorbereitet
worden ist und es ist mein jahrestag das
war kein zufall regelhüter und das macht
ihn ja in der situation
wirklich auch zu einem hampelmann
er hatte sich so schön angezogen dass er
so schön lässig aussieht mit seinem
wattierten mantel und irgendwie wirkte
er auch viriler und jugendlicher als in
manchen letzten auftritten es war alles
bis ins letzte detail und dann mitten in
seinem satz ist weg und es erscheint die
bilder von zuvor da haben wir jetzt mal
daran der ist ein dass sein das ist
sozusagen der erste anschlag auf putin
und zwar in einem bereich einer seiner
größten waffen nämlich der kommunikation
und wenn wir jetzt daran denken dass die
menschen die jetzt vom fernseher
gesessen haben möglicherweise vor einer
woche oder vor ein paar tagen als es
dabei eben amarena gesehen hat die
ebenfalls im selben kanal die
staatsfernsehen unterbrochen hat und das
kriegs plakat dorthin gehalten hat ein
paar tage später sehen die
oberbefehlshaber dort und der wird auch
wieder unterbrochen dann hat man doch
als einigermaßen vernünftige mensch das
gefühl hoppla gegen sonst irgendwas
stimmt nicht und wenn dieses gefühl sich
schon mal verbreiten würde dann sind ja
auch sind menschen aller nationen ja
wissbegierig und neugierig was stimmt
denn da nicht und dann wird sich auch
durch grandiose aktionen wie die von
arnold schwarzenegger mit seinem großen
video über das wir auch ausführlich
berichtet haben hier wird sich stück für
stück mensch für mensch dorf zu dorf
stadt für stadt schulklasse für
schulklassen dort wird aus deren sicht
das gift der wahrheit in die diskussion
kommen und das ist die eigentliche das
eigentliche schwert gegen putin zusammen
mit den sanktionen also wenn es uns
einmal einem bild vorstellen wir wollen
keinen krieg gegen ihn wir führen keinen
krieg wenn wir angegriffen werden denken
über neue als westliches bündnis aber
wir führen keinen krieg wir schicken
auch keine kampfjets aber unsere waffen
sind viel subtiler und vielleicht
schärfer wir haben ihn in einer
wirtschaftlichen notsituation
und es kommt schritt für schritt stück
für stück die wahrheit in sein land und
das kann die kraft entfalten am ende
diese furchtbare sonderoperation also
den krieg den blutigen krieg den er
angezettelt hat aus minderen gründen zu
beenden und in der tat selbst wenn man
im fernsehen doch da war irgendwie was
nur kurz das ist der moment über den
dann die leute abends sprechen hast du
das gesehen hast du das gehört und so
wird es sich dann auch rumsprechen und
ich weiß auch nicht also vielleicht
waren es ja doch zehn minuten und es
waren dann jetzt nur sechs
also der ist ja schon da bleibt so viel
spekulation das einzige was echt zu sein
scheint ist dass er wirklich selber da
war und auch das ist ja erstaunlich also
weiß ja vorher gerätselt worden kommt er
wirklich dahin wird er auf einer großen
videowand eingespielt der grund dafür
sechs minuten hin und erzählt
irgendetwas von militär und
glauben und und liebe als der
kriegstreiber der kriegsherr der
diktator der kriegsverbrecher wie joe
biden im nennt also das wird noch dass
das ereignis dieses tages und das zu
analysieren wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen